the Brussels attacks were the latest
show of terror and tyranny by the
so-called Islamic state but what is the
appeal of their brand of radicalism and
how to stop it before ordinary Muslims
pay the price at the European Parliament
a seminar brought together politicians
and Muslim think tanks the rise of
Islamophobia plays into the narrative of
Isis and dash because that's exactly
what they want they want some of the
Muslims to feel that they're not part
and parcel radicalization again Muslims
didn't begin with the war in Syria a
former Islamist tells a story the
killing of white blond blue-eyed Muslims
in Bosnia troubled me in troubled me
deeply and not seeing government's
respond to that made me think that the
way to combat the difficulty in Bosnia
and the Balkans by extension was to get
involved with extremist Islamist
organizations it took me a few years to
realize that by gathering on streets and
mobilizing and creating noise and
calling for jihad you don't necessarily
see an end to conflict but it's by
engaging with the democratic process we
need to invest in our young people
because if we don't invest in them there
are others out there that are clearly
investing in them there's an appetite
for revolution and now young people want
to join a revolution let's get them to
join the revolution that we've designed
for good can a revolution be realized
from the conference came one conclusion
dialogue was the key to stopping the
ideology of Islamism laying wrought to a
religion